dude I have come there well so that was
said I'm while I'm gonna be giving daddy
while I'm right by the law and mamma
halle better not be a marine boy hehe
penis it was another eat ketchup edition
was empathetic mean I mean I am a genie
and said volatile Oleg kerryman TallyMan
a pnina pnina what a female in Iowa
tarina in namaha ketemu saloon Allan
levy yeah you were living the sudden
wada he was selling mortis nima lama
tsong he was selling would what I
can in modern I'm what to hunt and were
top of I'll saed now from middle to
build will be whether ye ha well I
theater never daddy what she thought
yeah well humor in other sorry what the
ayah voila he was happy he was sending
Testament Catherine kaffir vamos ala
sayyidina from the damaja early sayidina
[Arabic recitation]
Ibrahim o Allah Sayyidina Ibrahim
follada mean in nica Hamida Maggie dear
brothers and sisters allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala says in the noble quran
worship allah and do not associate
partners with him and show guide this to
your parents a la sao paulo matada also
says which means your lord has commanded
that commanded that you do not worship
any but him and that you shall get
tightness to your parents if one or both
of them reaches of each with you do not
speak
I patiently with them Norris Cole then
speak to them would was with words of
kindness and lower that wings of
humility and mercy and say my lord
blonde am mercy as they raised me when I
was young these verses show that
worshipping Allah Subhan Ahmad Allah and
only allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is a duty
that confirms of la's greatness and
flavors on his servants the messenger
sallallahu alayhi wasallam said glorify
Allah commands and showed mercy to his
creatures and glorify Allah commands and
show mercy to his a glitch errors after
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala himself the
most wonderful blessing blessing is our
parents Allah Subhan Allah what Allah
says which means and we advised man to
care for his parents his mother carried
him in hardship after hardship and his
willing takes two years so give thanks
to me and to your parents and to me is
your return there are mothers and
sisters we are more example
in the Australian about Billie Holiday
oh my man Kanani was a respected man
among his people he had a son by the
name of killer killer migrated to Medina
the during the time of Romano haha la
diabla one after a short time there he
began to ask about the best kind of
working son he was told it was to fight
in the way of Allah subhana Allah he
went to st. armor of the other one to
sign up for their army and and be sent
to protect pizza when Elena's father
learned of this he said to kill of my
son don't leave your father and mother
in their weakness and and old age they
care for you when you were young and now
that you and know that they need you you
are leaving them Claude replied leave me
to what is best for me and he left
promising to return soon but collab was
done for a long time his guys a glue
older and missed their son if they saw a
belt calling to it
send they would begin to wind his father
soon became blind finally one day Kira's
father went to say it nemore the Apollo
the olive on and said to him if you
don't return my son to me I will
supplicate against you on the day of a
Lahad so st. number of the yellow and
cold killer back to Medina and ask it
and asked him how did you reach this
level of division to your parents club
replied I used to follow my father and
fulfill all his needs when I used to
bring their milk I would go to the best
color and make sure it was relaxed then
I would wish and hold on the others and
look it slowly so the color would feel
calm finally I would take that milk home
to my parents saved our blood iana one
then called for Elena and asked him what
is your wish today mainly replied I have
no I do not feel happiness at good
news no harm add
news I only would to feel and smell
my son near me before I die before
before calling his father say Tom Allah
Allah one had altered he left to go milk
a camel exactly the way he used to mark
it and bring the milk back to him once a
dollar how did the bull of milk to Elena
Nina said by Allah I smell the hands of
my son in this milk say drama rhodiola
one began to cry and say to him it is
indeed your Sankey lad who has come back
to you oh my man impressed his son and
all of the people there began to weep
they told club your job is with your
parents and to take care of them for the
rest of their lives you can do what you
after they are gone dear brothers
and sisters it is very important that
you know it is said that earning the
pleasure of Allah comes from earning the
pleasure of their parents and ending the
anger of a lot comes from adding the
anger of the all the parents the
messenger sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said beware beware of not being
beautiful to your parents the winds of
paradise that travel 500 years will not
carry will not carry the smell of a
thankless person omar bin abdul-aziz
bloody aha I know said do not make
friends with an angry fool person he
will not appreciate you if he does not
appreciate his parents there was no one
more beautiful to his parents than the
son of yeah yeah if the father like
Omaha who used to make sure his father
Madhu blue in World Water one cold night
when they
we're in prison they were forbidden from
any firewood so yeah but the water into
a couple cup and and held it in his
hands all night time to heat the water
for his father another example I mean
the son of hussein rhodiola one who
managed by eve was told you are the best
son and yet we do not see you eat with
your mother I mean blow the other one
replied I feel this obedience in case my
hand deaths that's hers to a morsel of
food that he'll eyes had listed upon
before nine one of the same used to seek
a las protection throne disobedient
child and say oh allah i seek refuge
from you from a thankless child and one
that will harm me dear brothers and
sisters also very important you know
this this this good manner do this good
manner when with your talents in their
non Muslim this is very important also
because Allah subhana Allah says well
enjoy kaya and crucially can be my life
selected here
fella total Mumma was on a human hit
dunya an alpha o Allah grant us from our
spouses and offspring they comfort of
our eyes and make us leaders among the
obedient a llama have the Navy as Regina
bhadoria Tina Carlotti Yuma welch allyn
Allyn Kapini mama oh mama heard an hour
from them go to Valley now Selena
watching our open up saw a hottie on
Molina Molina what you re Dina what is
yamaha tell holly nowell are eating him
well even a Shahada become women high
energy he did I him inhale in whatever
direction oh my god Anna lib arena allah
hoo kimberly Elena there are attending
que el Helani along minus M Khalid
Ansari haina really rottens I hotter
yahoo Bellamy Allah Almighty Shahada
nasty nima the amount to head to ottumwa
legit nip now I yahoo infection mahalo
mean how am I boppin Lawson will be
hustla can venir à la morte culero laura
i will be IDK latina a tall fellow a
[Arabic recitation]
muhammad nadeem on a la manera de
minimis femina su fecha de guate savita
to relay a la la nena esta mina fifa
lima can allow my leaping up Alou be
muslim EF equally McCann along
ha tomodachi da while in Alberta
immortalhd nada nah maybe Katara
coercion that nada mohamed I'm sorry
water you were seldom why should I wanna
any hunger desire of blood I mean he
know I I'm will be you it s on ye
tera a little puller bar when Hannah and
in faccia he wouldn't carry well Bobby
na boo boo now looking to the karoon
well addict remarkable playin solitaire
come come